hybridize
in between ideas or as I like to put it
ideas having sex is an absolutely
central feature of economic progress and
it's a very biological idea when you
think about it like that my name is Matt
Ridley I write nonfiction books mostly
about science human nature genetics
evolution and particularly recently
economics the Red Queen is a character
in through the looking-glass by Lewis
Carroll she runs very fast but never
gets anywhere she's always staying in
the same place however fast she runs and
this is a metaphor that was used that is
used in evolution to describe arms races
that that argument can explain a
surprising amount about human nature
that an awful lot of what we do is
sexually selected in the sense of being
likes a male ambition you know to
succeed in life is all about trying to
get ahead in the red queen race with
with respect to make choice there is
little doubt that that rock and roll
guitar heroes are considered sexy and
virtuosity talent high status these are
things that lead to genetic success
through being able to acquire the right
kind of mates it's very hard to say
exactly what sort of natural way of
mating in our species is but one thing
we can get a few clues from comparing
with other animals so it looks like were
a pair bonding species where males and
females form long term pair bonds and
both help bring up the children but like
in a lot of pair bonding species and
this work comes mainly from birds which
also do this that doesn't necessarily
mean that the female is going to accept
that male being the only father of her
children in other words she wants a
partner who will help bring up the
children but she might want to get some
better G
seems from another guy that's what
happens in a lot of birds that are very
similar in their social structure to
human beings it's an intriguing thought
I wouldn't particularly want to be a
bonobo because females are dominant in
bonobos and males do what they're told
ok I be quite fun to be a chimpanzee
because you get a ton of sex but there
be an awful lot of fighting orangutangs
are very solitary I don't think that
sounds a lot of fun and Gibbons are a
bit like humans they live in pairs and
bring up families together so yeah the
life of the silverback alpha male
gorilla is probably the most
spectacularly idle and enjoyable one in
that sense but you'd have to put up with
the fact that after a while you're gonna
get beaten up and probably killed and
that when you first came into the troop
you'd have to kill a lot of babies which
doesn't you know those sounds like
things that I would enjoy morality comes
from both our animal past and our very
specifically more recent human past in
the sense that there are things we do
which other animals also do and that we
did when we were animals and like build
trusting relationships with them and
there are things we do now as human
beings that other animals don't do that
require us to be nice and virtue equals
cooperative behavior there is a very
strong pressure within human society to
spot and ostracize antisocial people and
to reward and encourage pro-social
people but the most exciting thing to
come out of the genome project was the
stunning realization the the complete
surprise that there are no human genes
well there are a few but that we've
basically got the same genes as a
or a chimpanzee or a whale or a dolphin
or a dog that all mammals have the same
21,000 genes give or take a couple of
hundred we didn't expect that the
nature-nurture debate is a is an old and
tired debate that's gone on for
centuries about whether we're born or
made
and I think it got utterly reinvigorated
and partially solved when genomes were
sequenced and we began to understand how
genes worked because what it emerged was
that genes which you think of as nature
are actually to some extent at the mercy
of our behavior our culture and our
environment which we think of as nurture
and even in laying down a memory in your
brain you have to switch on a bunch of
genes 17 genes in the brain every time
you lay down a memory in real time it's
a much more interesting than just saying
it's a bit of both it's saying the two
interact in a dynamic way my next
project is a book which I'm trying to
write to understand what it is that's
different about human beings from other
species focusing particularly on the
role of exchange and specialization
clearly we're different from our
immediate ancestors in that we've we
left to a nearly 7 billion people we've
taken over the planet we've done these
extraordinary things in just a few tens
of thousands of years with a brain and
not particularly bigger than the one
that we had before that what changed and
I think it was exchange and
specialization that we got into the
habit of the division of labor
Darwyn got his idea of spontaneous order
from the political economists I think
that's pretty explicit he was reading
Adam Smith himself he was really Malthus
he was reading Harriet Martineau people
like this and he was he was getting this
idea of emergent spontaneous order from
the tradition of empirical philosophers
and and and political economists and
actually I'm interested in seeing
whether the favor can now be returned
and some of the insights from
evolutionary biology can illuminate
economics one aspect of human nature
that is absolutely central to the
economic system is the ability to trust
people to the extent that economic
systems allow people to develop those
relationships call them contracts if you
like then they work well to the extent
that they come in and interfere with
those contracts and impose a top-down
solution on the way people do things I
don't think they do work as well and I
feel it's very important to understand
the world as a bottom-up place a place
where solutions emerge rather than are
imposed from above
there is no doubt that most people don't
think in terms of positive some
interactions we're obsessed with the
idea of who's won and who's lost in an
interaction and often both people win
and it's not true that someone's won and
someone's lost and that leads to this
thinking that things are zero-sum it
leads to mercantilism that exports are
good and imports are bad it leads to
Marxism that bosses are profiting and
workers are suffering or vice versa and
and the world just isn't like that
writing a book about how humanity got to
where it is today has made be even more
optimistic than I was before the average
person on the world is three times as
well off as he was 50 years ago despite
there being three times as many people
we've got we've cut infant mortality by
70 percent in that period on average
throughout the world we've we've
increased lifespan on average throughout
the world by 30 percent these are
incredible achievements recessions
depressions
they're blips in the graph they're
horrible blips when they happen and
they're deeply uncomfortable for many
individuals but the long-run trend is
that exchange and specialization are
going to increase and spread throughout
the world and at the same time we're
gonna get nicer because all the evidence
suggests that the more integrated we are
into markets and into commerce the nicer
we are not the nastier we are so I think
in in a hundred years time everybody's
going to be better off happier and nicer
and a huge optimist about the future